I want a breakfast sandwich right now
jack-in-the-box has the best breakfast
McDonald's McDonald's all day everyday
everything is nicely layered and clearly
processed this is like a breakfast
sandwich you get in middle school this
croissant is on point I think Oh
breakfast challenge everything's got the
right textures but the flavor is just
not there this one looks like the eggs
are so fake there's a steak sausage just
thought this is amazing this is too much
bread I don't appreciate this oh I'm
loving this everybody I take is better
than last one this one has to be
McDonald's that one's McDonald's oh it
smells like alcohol and pancakes nope
nevermind something coffee y'all good
presentation I want to look at the meat
huh huh there's very little cheese no
cheese no that's the worst one yet yeah
this is the worst smelling one by far
yeah this smells like McDonald's cuz
it's cheese like it just looks like
Frankenstein she usually looks orange
McDonald's is symmetrical you can tell
McDonald's cuz it's like very clearly
made by machines it's not great it's
pretty good it's like America and this
is McDonald's I'm really disappointed
too gonz yeah this would only be like if
I was free and if like there wasn't a
banana around
oh my god stupid on the bread okay why
is this sausage so dark or oh my god
squeeze it yeah this biscuit feels great
it tastes homemade it tastes like my
grandma's biscuits breads drowning out
the rest of this if they fix their bun
to meat ratio you got a winner
everything came across up clean except
for the cheese left a little bit of
residue ha ha this egg looks real real
like it was made on a griddle everything
has butter in it it's amazing this is
good it's really like the most mild in
flavor I don't like the egg but that's
just whip it up throw it out the window
this has to be with adults it has to be
overall I choose this one uh
jack-in-the-box it's delicious yeah
dragonbugs so good that one is still my
favorite this one was my favorite
it was so good yeah is this
so that was jack-in-the-box
okay I called it from the beginning
there's like Ryan Gosling and this is
George Clooney
hi this one's just like a little bit
more like sophisticated as a lot better
yeah what's this one
that's just Gabe you see that's that's
prettier than anything